i want to address now
one of the most common arguments that
the right is making against the student
loan debt forgiveness
this is unfair
to people who already paid off their
student loans or don't have student
loans this is the argument that many
right wingers are now making well
whatever you can say about the merits of
helping people who currently have
student loan debt
it's very unfair to those who don't have
student loan debt or to those who worked
hard to pay off their student loan debt
already joe biden yesterday during a
press conference that he gave a press
took questions at the end of a statement
i guess is a better way to say it
uh was asked about this what about the
people who paid off their student loans
is this unfair to people who paid their
student loans or chose not to take out
loans
is it fair to people who in fact do not
own the multi-billion dollar businesses
they've seen why these guys give them
all the taxes is that fair
what do you think
what about people who paid their loans
so struggle to pay their loans and now
others don't have to all right so that's
peter ducey there at the end yelling out
a question so let's talk about that i
paid off my student loans i had student
loans i could have waited
um i don't care if joe biden forgives
everybody else's loans first of all this
is good for the economy it's demand side
stimulus when people aren't paying
interest
to big mega lenders
that money they then have to put into
their local economy small businesses
maybe they can get a david pakman show
membership now because they don't have
to funnel that money
into these mega financial corporations
so it's good for the economy and i like
things that are good for the economy so
could i have waited and taken a chance
that someday
maybe joe biden would or someone would
pay off some forgive some student loans
and maybe i would be under the income
limit but maybe i would not sure i could
have done that but i didn't and it's
it's just not a problem for me but
here's the other thing the people that
already paid off their student loans yes
they they don't get the forgiveness
but they freed up money for other things
much sooner so i get it
you you went through the struggle of
paying off your student loans three
years ago
and now you're missing out on 10k
possibly 20k
but three years ago you were able to
redirect the money that had and would
have been going to your student loans if
you're relatively financially competent
to savings to building an emergency fund
to starting a retirement account to
contributing to low-cost index funds or
whatever so it's not like you just lost
because you paid off your loans and now
there's forgiveness
you have freed up that money to do other
things with during the intervening time
to improve your financial position so
it's a very silly argument now you can
take this idea
and apply it to almost anything i mean
listen it would be unfair if republicans
were to now cut taxes
because look at all these people who for
all these years paid a higher tax rate
well that that doesn't really make sense
they never make that argument
i n me i'm talking now is me david i
didn't get a federal tax credit for my
electric vehicle but now they're putting
in new tax credits for electric vehicles
that's not fair to me well yeah it's
okay life's not always necessarily fair
but i got my vehicle earlier rather than
burning gas for the last three years
waiting for the credit i've had an
electric vehicle and i've reduced my
fueling expense i mean come on yeah i
saw on twitter
every black person should still have to
be a slave because it's not fair to the
former slaves i mean it's an absurd
thing right
we're expanding it into absurd arguments
but it's more or less the principle i
saw on reddit
would it be unfair to the people that
the trolley has already killed
to divert it now to prevent it from
killing more people
uh that's a trolley problem one so those
are all terrible criticisms now here is
a good criticism and again it's a
criticism but we're talking about
different things here is a fair
assessment of what the forgiveness does
not do i guess what i find
annoying about it is that it doesn't
address the higher education cartel and
it basically is infusing money into a
higher education system that is
basically just corrupt at this point you
look at how much tuition has just
skyrocketed over the last 20 30 years i
mean my college tuition i it was it's
three times today what it was 20 years
ago and that's just absurd and it
doesn't do any that's not accessible for
the majority of americans so that's
absolutely true that's msnbc analyst
elise jordan and she correctly points
out this doesn't address the
skyrocketing cost of college it doesn't
do that and that's why joe biden and
others have said well we should have
free community college start putting in
place
lower cost competition to the higher
education cartel to put some downward
pressure on prices that's absolutely
accurate this doesn't do that
this is debt relief it's not an
institutional reform
they're both related to education but
they are independent issues and what
should be done next is we need to figure
out how to deal with the pricing issue
absolutely this doesn't fix that
but that doesn't mean the forgiveness is
a bad idea so some real brain rot
happening on the right uh right wingers
uh on the brains of right-wingers in the
united states as a result of this i
think part of what's going on is they
realize this is very bad for them in
november and after the break we're going
to talk about that i want to remind you
that next wednesday
6 p.m eastern time we are going to be
doing our first in a really long time
members only town hall we've done
monthly town halls open to everybody and
we're going to continue doing those this
wednesday we're doing a member only town
hall which if eddie but it will be
streamed live anybody who wants to watch
it is welcome to
but only join pacman.com members
will be welcome to call in and chat with
me okay so sign up at joinpacman.com
that town hall coming up wednesday
august 31st at 6 pm eastern 3 p.m
pacific it's going to be a good one
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium cbd designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report cbd helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use cbd as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels cbd oil is awesome the cbd infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about cbd dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today get fifty percent off your first
order with free shipping when you go to
feels.com davidp and use the code davidp
the link is down below